A desperate and politically wounded Joe
Biden is trying to change the subject
after a terrible start to the year the
big guy's already bad poll numbers are
sinking fast and he faces an onslaught
of Investigations in his first major
speech since losing the house Biden says
to hell with working with the GOP to
make your lives better he is looking for
a fight ditching the Kumbaya talk and
unleashing on Republicans who are trying
to rein in his Reckless spending
this ain't your father's Republican
party this is a different
breed of cat as they say tiger
Republicans deliberately choose to
inflict this kind of pain on the
American people why why as I said they
seem determined to be the party of chaos
and catastrophe and now these Maggie
Republicans introduce another bill it's
going to eliminate the IRS gonna
eliminate it completely the only guys
can go in and look at the complicated
tax returns that people have
and replace the IRS
which I'd be nice no longer no no taxes
right except with a 30 percent national
sales tax now let me be clear
if any of these bills somehow got passed
the house and the Senate I will veto
them
well okay well let me start with
what is it sorry guys I was so stunned
by that too but Joe isn't going this
alone the White House seems to have sent
Democrats the same talking points
it's a silly doggone idea and uh and
like I said uh Over My Dead Body we'll
fight uh we'll fight every day until
this thing goes down to defeat what are
the Republicans doing team extreme the
team
consisting of extremists
who are willing to detonate the American
economy it feels like Republicans only
want to have these extreme discussions
when a Democrat is occupying the White
House
Dana I'll go back to you again
um taking the offense when you're really
in charge of an economy that is a
disaster gas prices are up 50 and I
won't even go through the list the
Republicans should just play that cardi
B clip over and over again like wait how
did the economy get this bad why is
everything so expensive how are people
supposed to live because that actually
has a lot of pull I have to say I think
the Democrats they are crass they are
doing exactly what you would want to do
politically to put them in a position to
help him run for reelection he goes to
Virginia today that's an important state
for them it's pretty much a purplish
State because
uh Obama had done very well there
um but youngkin won right as a
republican that's just a purple state so
they got it locked down Virginia he's
doing a lot of these things before the
State of the Union on February 7th and
you're going to see more of it he's
doing two fundraisers for the DNC next
week so the White House is doing
everything that they need to do to put
him in position to run they are not
letting him do a lot of interviews
you'll notice that because he's got the
document issue that he has to deal with
and they also pre-release so much of the
speech including punch lines and jokes
because they want those to be in the
media the print media because you're not
going to necessarily get a clean sound
bite and that's fine they know that
about him but they also know okay what
are the Republicans weak on
you see this for the Republicans at
least they're talking about ideas okay
let's talk can we not at least have a
discussion about what we're going to do
if Social Security runs out of money in
2033 that's just 10 years from now and
you're thinking about kids like Cleo and
Jesse Jr and your grandson and Cami
I'm like I know that kid's name yeah and
you know we we can actually have a
conversation As Americans to say what
would actually be a good way to preserve
Medicare and Social Security going in
the future it's ridiculous to suggest
that people are going to all of a sudden
have a 30 national retail sales tax on
top of all the taxes they're already
paying that's not what the proposal is
besides Kevin McCarthy already said is
not going anywhere other Republicans
have said it's not going anywhere I
don't fault them for at least having
ideas what I do fault is the media for
not asking Joe Biden and the Democrats
well what is your idea is your idea to
just pass so much in spending that you
cause inflation and then look back and
say this was all caused by the Trump tax
cuts of 2017 that doesn't make any sense
Biden wants to run his last campaign and
the media shouldn't let him do it all
right so I'll go right to you Jessica I
mean didn't Joe Biden go on the biggest
spending spree in American history no
Donald Trump actually spent a lot more
than him so Donald Trump is personally
responsible as the president for about
30 percent of the national debt and I
believe uh Joe Biden's brought it down
by 1.4 trillion since he's been in
office
I was asked a question I answered it
Donald Trump is responsible for more of
the national debt than Joe Biden his
period end of story those are what the
numbers say we also had a good jobs
report today or a good economic reporter
now Brian you spoke about it this
morning on Fox and Friends 2.9 fourth
quarter growth 2.1 percent increase in
consumer spending those are good
indicators when people are talking about
all the layoffs the layoffs are in one
sector in Tech and basically they're
right sizing the fact that they over
hired in 2021 at 2021 sorry and 2022. so
they're going back to the mean there
they paid people way too much gave
people big fancy titles they couldn't
afford to do that so I'm not for calling
everybody a Maga Republican I know that
was part of what he was talking about
today but he does have an economic
record to run on and he does have the
fact that you have important
Representatives so much so that people
thought that he could be speaker or this
Kevin Hearn who said we have to make
these uh we have to make uh hard
decisions about what's going on with
Social Security and Medicare and he's
part of a conference of 160 conservative
Republicans who have said that they want
to look at changing the retirement age
that's something that Nancy Mays for
instance a republican said is absolute
not non-starter McCarthy said that as
well but get your caucus in line if you
don't want Democrats talking about the
fact that there are people in your
conference who are important to you by
the way saying that we should raise the
retirement age people are going to pay
attention to it and they're going to
vote accordingly didn't Kevin Hearn get
one vote for speakers yes I mean what
he's telling you more than the rest of
them
no of course not but he's not I don't
know the truth is that when Donald Trump
left office inflation was 1.7 inflation
under Joe Biden has gone what to 8789 I
mean come on it's the highest in 40
years let's talk about the truth the
truth is that that you've got a 41 50
increase in fuel eggs I don't have to
tell you what Americans are going
through and yeah the economy is great I
don't think so what you meant about
cardi B is the everyday person who goes
shopping that that's what the economy
feels like and to your point Dana on
politics this is my point with media I
just thought they'd get some clicks on
on uh this morning from what I said my
point this morning was
two months after the election which
we're doing politics if there was ever a
time to lead the country and not your
party it's two months after an election
and you haven't said I'm running for
reelection again so just tell me your
vision you don't have to say I wonder
what buddy Carter wants to do now the
fair tax might have some possibilities
but politically it's not the strongest
thing but it's one congressman who
brings it Forward just like Rick Scott
brings one thing forward and he grabs
onto it and I just said to myself he's
80 years old if you do want to talk
about the economy and you do want to say
be honest about it he still should be
upset at the inflation's high he should
just talk about energy in the decision
he's making agreeing the economy he
should talk about the things that are
bothering the fact that the job Market's
starting to go a little wobbly and say
if for his point of view I'd say look I
want things to be a little bit better
I'm proud of what I've done but I think
you should get the big picture and
compare you to other countries Joe
Biden's strongest argument I think is if
you compare our economy to other
countries we're doing good my point was
you don't always have to make the
Republicans the villain I understand
elections but be the president for once
this is what I did this is what's
disappointing me this is what's wearing
me but I'll tell you in the big picture
when I look around and I meet with the
European leaders we're pretty much doing
better than everyone except for maybe
inflation with uh with Japan that was
that was my point
okay all right Jesse the economy is
about a feel and the economy doesn't
feel good for the American people right
now because wages are down and last
year's stock market was down year to
year so we're not making money as of
last year
and if you add the gas prices and nasty
inflation and the fact they had to jack
up mortgage rates you can't afford to
buy a house and people are not it's like
renter Nation
there is good stuff he had a good GDP
number he had stronger GDP numbers last
year and there's consumer spending the
job numbers have been strong but people
are getting laid off in Tech because
we're preparing for a light recession
everybody knows there's going to be a
light recession next year
I don't like when Republicans propose
big New Economic ideas when they're not
in power I like having ideas just keep
those ideas to yourself and wait for the
campaign to start campaign's two years
away I'm not showing a lot of skin right
now you're like a boxer you know what I
mean all of a sudden you're out here out
here and then he just lands shot to the
body 30 sales tax maybe that's a good
idea that's not but I mean he's opening
up big big gaping holes for Joe to
attack and then what's the other thing
that this guy in Florida wants to slash
entitlements you don't do that you don't
say that it's just not a smart idea one
had another deal with entitlements tell
everybody that's about 18 to 30 to start
having babies have a lot of babies
that'll help with entitlements we should
raise the retirement age by the way they
wrote they wrote Social Security in the
fifties
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now